seit 2013 gibt es sie wenn ja in ihren
songs geht es um kinder heirat gewalt
gegen frauen oder fehlende
bildungschancen viele mädchen haben
keinen schulabschluss durch wenn ja hat
sich etwas verändert
76 prozent der fans sagen sie gehen
wieder in die schule und 84 prozent von
ihnen meinen die band hat sie
selbstbewusster gemacht
mission erfüllt
der name dieser erfolgreichen
äthiopischen band bedeutet auf am
harisch unser denn sie gehören zu ihren
fans
ihre musik steht für sozialen wandel und
die selbstbestimmung von frauen
unsere rix haben einen tiefen sinn und
sind lehrreich
wir sprechen wichtige themen an die fünf
frauen machen aber nicht nur musik
sondern drehen filme haben eine talkshow
und ein eigenes hörspiel jede von ihnen
spielt einen bestimmten charakter er
jerusalem ist die strebsame sie bieber
die musikliebhaberin treff das city girl
rahel die mütterliche und ländern
das straßenkind alles wird intensiv
vorbereitet besondere an uns ist das
script wird geschrieben nachdem wir
bestimmte orte besucht haben dort
recherchieren wir damit wir anschließend
eine echte story erzählen können
da sind wir persönlich zu echten
charakteren gegangen und haben uns
angeschaut wie sie sich fühlen was für
ein leben sie für die probleme der
charaktere orientieren sich an der
realität
häusliche gewalt zwangsehe und armut
themen mit denen sich viele mädchen in
äthiopien identifizieren können ihnen
will genia helfen perspektiven und
lösungsansätze sollen betroffene
hörerinnen stärken
die arbeit hat sie bieber verändert wenn
ich eine frau auf der straße sehe die
probleme hat laufe ich nicht einfach
vorbei ich gehe hin zu ihr und versuche
mit ihr zu sprechen
außerdem fängt alles zu hause an es
fängt damit an dass man seine familie
seine schwester respektiert mich daher
in vielerlei hinsicht verändert
vor drei jahren kamen alle über ein
casting in die band seitdem sind sie oft
in äthiopien unterwegs und echte promis
wird ihre arbeit erreichen sie rund
sieben millionen radiohörer abgehoben
sind sie trotzdem nicht
sie mögen den regelmäßigen kontakt zu
ihren fans
ich möchte gerne wie sie seien alles an
ihnen macht mich glücklich kenia will
aber nicht nur mädchen oder frauen
erreichen
gleichberechtigung geht alle an finden
sie daher spielt der 28 jährige seele im
kassa in ihrer radioshow einen kumpel
der sich mit ihnen für die rechte von
frauen stark macht das erreicht auch
männliche hörer wie den friseur tarik
allen wie ich höre wird vielen frauen
und sogar müttern viel leid angetan
ich hätte vorher nicht gedacht dass
frauen vergewaltigt werden
die zeiten haben sich geändert
mittlerweile werden selbst mutter
geschlagen oder vergewaltigt das zu
wissen hat auch meine haltung gegenüber
meinen schwestern und meiner mutter
verändert
und das dank jena über solche fans
freuen sich die fünf
sie geben ihnen das gefühl dass sie mit
ihrer arbeit auf dem richtigen weg sind